would you call yourself a pessimist or a
optimist well i
when asked that i always appeal to the
slogan that uh antonio gramsci made
famous
uh we should have pessimism of the
intellect
and optimism of the will
there's a lot of things that are wrong
that's what we should concentrate on
trying to make them better and we should
be optimistic about the power to do so
no matter what the obstacles yeah it
almost reminds me of uh
you you studied obviously a lot of
philosophy i'm assuming you also studied
probably stoicism with seneca and you
know marcus aurelius and
and the whole how stoicism got started
with prior to what it used to be called
cynicism and couple guys are like listen
i'm i don't want to be part of this
cynicism community it was a philosophy
and
you know seneca kind of stepped away and
says i'm just going to go do something
else and then boom stoicism got started
uh into what it is today but it was it
was more of the mindset of
i can do something about my life to
improve my life do you believe the
individual
has the ability and the control and the
responsibility and the ultimate level of
accountability to help
improve their situation and their lives
not just your own life
but to improve the world for all of us
and those are right now are the most
urgent questions that have ever faced
the human species after all we
might not like to think about it but we
have about it
a decade or two to answer the question
as to whether organized human life will
persist on earth nothing
less than that very historic question
how certain are you of that to say a
decade or two that's a pretty extreme
statement to say we only have a decade
or two why do i say that
yes it's a fact if we don't if we don't
deal with the increase
of heating the environment
we will reach tipping points which are
irreversible doesn't mean everybody's
going to die tomorrow but we'll be off
on a course
which will be unstoppable and will lead
to
essentially the end of organized human
life on earth
along with millions of other species
which we're destroying at the same time
i can't be certain about this but
there's a very
high probability of it in fact virtual
unanimity among scientists that this is
what's going to happen
unless we take control within the next
few decades
so to say it's a fact that's that's a
pretty strong uh statement to say it's a
fact
fact means like you know a hundred
percent we're going to be there
and nothing is a hundred percent okay
quantum theory is not a hundred percent
theory of relativity is not a hundred
percent
in the empirical world you never have
certainty
i'm just saying you said fact i'm just
repeating you said facts i think what
you're saying
there's a possibility but not
necessarily factual yes but that's
there's a background understanding since
the 17th century
that in the world of empirical fact
you never reach certainty so when we
talk about
facts as we do freely we always mean it
with that
qualification in the background we're
not going to stop using the word
fact like it's a fact
that if i take this coffee cup
and i let go of it it's a fact that
it'll fall to the ground
so there in fact is a very slight
possibility
that it will rise to the sky okay it
happens to be the case
uh things there's a spectrum of
possibilities of which the
overwhelmingly high probability
so high that there's no need in the
practical world to consider
anything else as it'll fall to the
ground but there does
happen to be a very miniscule
possibility that it might go to the sky
but when we talk about facts we have
that understanding in the background
yeah i mean i just never seen anything
fall up and i've lived 42 years i've had
a hard time seeing i mean if things
would have gone up and i would have
jumped a little higher i would have been
in the nba today so i'm hoping that was
kind of favoring me but i couldn't jump
more than 15 inches so
i could never go into the nba so
factually some of this stuff maybe i got
some work
done actually there is not that you
would do it but it's just one of the
things that could happen
in the universe so yeah it could happen
in the universe but that's a good that's
not a fact though that's a
but to say factually in the next 10 or
20 years that makes somebody sit there
and say
2 times 2 is 4. that's a fact 2 times 2
is not going to be five tomorrow there's
a possibility to be five tomorrow
that that puts a lot of fear in some
folks who have who haven't read as much
as you have to say
to say the world you know we're going in
the direction with climate change in 10
or 20 years that's a scary thought
no sorry that's a misunderstanding so
every
empirical fact that you can think of
has a possibility of being wrong
whatever it is that's been understood
for centuries
that's different that's that could be
your opinion my opinion
research who wrote it it's not a matter
of opinion
by now modern physics even explains it
in some detail
so it doesn't mean we should stop
talking about facts of course we should
but we should talk about facts with a
recognition
always barely possible sometimes almost
inconceivably small probability that
they're wrong
so we continue to talk about facts so
when i say
it's a fact that this is going to happen
that means there's an overwhelmingly
high probability
and we know the reason i think there's a
bigger factors and so on
if you want every statement that's ever
made
to be added to this qualification okay
i don't think that's a wise policy we
should continue to talk about facts
sure so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye